so this is one of our operating theaters
that's currently under repair NHS
leaders are used to working under
pressure but here at Friendly Park
Hospital time is running out we've been
working at this since last October
almost two-thirds of the roof here is
made of concrete that is breaking down
it's known as rack and it's falling
apart
this was identified a number of years
ago and we've had an extensive
surveillance and safety program in place
that's enabled us to identify any issues
or risks before they happen and as you
can see take remedial action and
reinforcement where they're needed but
importantly that isn't a long-term
solution the Queen Elizabeth's Hospital
in King's Lynn is facing the same
challenge in all seven hospitals have
until 2030 to fix their buildings or
face being closed down
now they're all being included in the
government's new hospitals program
today's announcement confirms over 20
billion pounds of investment for the NHS
estate it confirms that all seven black
hospitals which NHS leaders have called
on the government to provide prioritize
will be prioritized but relief for some
means delays for others eight large
schemes at hospitals like Preston Royal
Berkshire and St Mary's in London will
now be delayed until after 2030. leaking
sewage rat infestations collapsing roofs
we are in this mess because of
conservative neglect and mismanagement
they literally didn't fix the roof while
the Sun was shining and now patient
safety is at risk in addition to the new
hospitals program the government has
also announced plans to give patients
more control over where they receive
their health care including private
options
the Prime Minister has promised to bring
down the seven million strong elective
waiting list
GPS welcome the principle of Greater
choice but say that it could present
more work without addressing the issue
what we're not doing is we're not
increasing capacity we do have a set
number of appointments available and we
have a set number of patients and
unfortunately the rate of patients
increasing population growth versus
their appointments are available
clinical staff is not matching
new hospitals more choice for patients
both welcome but reliant on a Workforce
plan that is yet to be published oh
she's Josh is Sky News at frimley Park
Hospital